[Music]
that's the guy who's replacing me
[Music]
you're really quitting
it's time my brother's gone without
jackson i've got nothing else left to
fight for here so you just run away so
much for all that bravado i need to get
back to my family whatever's left of
them
you built a family here
forget it
[Music]
first time i've been at this a while
young buck stay behind me i'll keep you
safe keep me wait did it take you like
40 tries to get in the game you shut up
this is my last match not going home
without a win
something's coming come on what now
whoa
okay that thing must have triggered some
kind of security protocol nothing good
can come from this place huh
hey that shield just for
me you know sure of us have actually
been doing this for a while
now we're talking
wait what's your problem
[Music]
[Music]
whenever you're ready
come on mate i was just kidding
[Music]
oh
hey with me advanced together
right let's finish
[Music]
this awesome
checkmate
you good yeah
thank you
my arm is a little banged up but i'll be
all right
good
because you've got a lot to answer for
jackson
[Music]
wow clean up on aisle nine am i right
you get it it's like ah
[Music]
[Music]
you